I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense so I kind of wanted to go back
to the very beginning of us as teammates
okay when I got to know you and how you
know you're a joker you're funny you you
boys would play your pranks back in the
day of course my favorite one is where
you and Dario who was it was you Dario
Franchitti Bryan Bryan Herta all [ __ ]
and Dan Wheldon's toilet and wasn't that
in Japan in Japan and you crank the heat
and we took the water out of the toilet
that was a first-class man everybody
went did you organize that so that was
actually a debate which I'm I'm not
picky about that stuff so I can go to
the bathroom anywhere that I do it at
any time apparently yes wow that's I
think you have IBS but you know within
them Dario gets on oh I gotta go for
someone guys who ever figure out so we
emptied the toilet it's got a disgusting
conversation and we took we closed the
water out any flushes there was no oh my
god and he couldn't flush it oh my god
and four guys went I was the last one
which wasn't Pleasant like oh yeah
that's pretty intense and we cranked the
heat on in his bedroom and we left so
the way I got the key I actually
impersonated that I was Dan Wheldon in
Japan did they didn't know better then
wasn't that famous yet so that's how I
got his room key without being asked for
an ID it was funny it's back in the day
before they needed your blood type and
correct your passport number and
everything but the other day I locked
myself out of my room in the hotel and
obviously I didn't my I don't carry my
ID with him with me I went to grab some
ice and she wouldn't I didn't remember
my room number as you know I mean it
took me a little bit because we stay
like you know when you stay like three
nights in a row in three different
hotels like remember where you are when
you wake up and she wouldn't give me a
kiss at Wally Burgan I have to go up
there with me so I can prove it because
it can't I'm not just walking in here
and try anyway but yeah that was the
probably the the biggest prank yeah so
the point of the question in that face
tastic story is is I don't feel like you
guys pranked me no but we you know like
here's the thing I mean you come to the
team and and and you know here's this
little girl and and you're stronger you
have a really strong personality kind of
intimidating at times and you're like
she could hit me if I do something but
also we got told that you know remember
boys are boys and I know nowadays you I
know you wait a minute you get your
wings clipped
you can totally take it but we're like
guys you have to like don't you can do
stuff for to her but do not exaggerate
the way you guys do this or toilet yeah
so and then you know then you you you
just like yours you used to get fiery so
we like we backed off we're like that
holy well do you feel like I've tamed
down a little bit am I more calm then I
then I was when you remember meeting me
and in the beginning no good no just
about different things right I think you
were learning the house are going
through yourself a little more obviously
as years goes by I think you've learned
but also you know nowadays you probably
know that a lot better than me once
you're in the spotlight you gotta
unfortunately think about three times
once before you really react and I think
back in the days the good part was you
didn't care you know you didn't like
something yeah you're gonna go after
that well I mean I used to I did used to
I mean I used to fly off the handle bars
all the time the one time I was walking
down pit lane the race is still going on
it was Michigan we were delayed for like
three hours because of the rain and then
all the sudden it was drivers to your
cars when we were green flag in fifteen
laps and it was the second longest race
of the year next an Indy 500 and I I
think we sat in the car for 45 minutes
before we even rolled off because they
were still trying to dry weepers and I
wasn't brave enough to get out and go to
the bathroom because I thought sure
enough they're gonna call us to go and
but anyway and I remember I think I ran
out of gas like six laps to go and I was
so pissed off and I was like throwing my
helmet down my earpiece is down I'm
walking out pit lane I kick a barrel and
the barrel was empty and I thought it
was full of water and I was like oh
I picked the barrel of my strings I was
like oh no but I mean like I said what
you probably would do differently today
so I think you haven't changed needing
and I don't think you have
[Music]